I just gave him a bitch-slap from hell
they've already done about like five
wire gags I've never seen before
hey what's up guys my name is Travis
Wong I'm a professional fight and stunt
coordinator for film and television
based out of Los Angeles California I
was a fight coordinator of Marvel's
Legion season two and three and just
started stunt coordinating minions two
for Universal we're gonna take a look at
some action scenes from around the world
specifically looking at some Bollywood
films from over in India now while the
film community continues to grow over
there the level of action is also
expanding they're continuing to create
amazing content now with that being said
India is kind of known for some very
over-the-top and outlandish scenes so
let's take a look at some of these films
it just gave them a bitch-slap from hell
[Music]
they've already done about like five
wire gags I've never seen before a wire
dag is actually something that relates
to wire rigging and that is just
generally any type of scene where we use
a stunt performer and we have fix them
or attach them to a wire or cable a
shout-out to all the stunt guys in this
scene they are just going for it just
getting destroyed
I love it he just bought 50 guys and
then got hit by one guy from the back
who then had his life saved by some guy
with a gun that was pretty epic the one
thing that's cool about these scenes is
that they really like cross the line
between fantasy and realism I saw about
five to ten different wire gags in there
that I've never seen before the scenes
over in India we're using them in very
unique ways ways that we haven't used
them before at the entertainment value
wise I'd have to say it was a nine for
me as far as practicality is concerned
into being real definitely give it about
it to don't think that any man can take
on that many guys at once I don't think
that was the goal of this movie so props
to you guys oh look at the costumes on
this one
guy just got kicked and did three spins
while doing a backflip landed on him on
a wall like he's spider-man
I have so many questions never seen
anything quite like that that was
absolutely insane that falling in line
with you know the true Bollywood theme
here taking things that you would never
even consider to be a weapon and in this
case utilizing the single best tongue on
a scale of one to 10 as far as
entertainment Valley's concerned
Bollywood is coming through I got to
give that a solid eight or nine again I
really think that the cool thing about
all these scenes is that they cater to
all ages and all demographics and then
again if we're grading it on a scale of
realism from one to ten definitely a one
maybe maybe a half in between there a
lot of the superhero scenes that I do
like I said are obviously fantasy but
they're more grounded in realism and
they just have what we like to say you
know for lack of a better term Captain
America strength we like to say Captain
America strength is three times a normal
human but at the same time Captain
America still walks on two feet he still
runs around the one universal thing is
that all of them have amazing powers and
directors and the stunt teams are just
trying to portray those in the best way
possible
oh we are in a gym full of bodybuilders
in speedos let's go the one thing that
I'm gonna say right away is for these
guys sake I hope that the ground was
padded or that they don't have to hit
the ground because clearly no one is
wearing pads right now
spending 350 to 400 pounds right now
take it out guys
that was probably the first legit real
fall that I've seen today and that was
nice that was a nice one that was
probably the closest to a realistic
fight scene in the beginning cool thing
about that scene that a lot of people
don't take into account is the lack of
pads that the guys were able to wear and
this is something in our industry that I
give a lot of credit and respect to
stunt women throughout the world anytime
you see a stunt woman doing a car hit in
a dress or she's in a swimsuit she's not
wearing pads just like these guys were
in the scenes far as entertainment value
is concerned I would give this one like
it's solid eight I'd say it wasn't as
over-the-top as some of the other ones
was concerned and as far as realism I'm
actually gonna give this one a little
bit higher than normal I'm gonna bump
this one up to about a three I saw some
choreography points that I would have
done very similarly so uh yeah man shout
it to you guys this looks like a
throwback film oh you know this is gonna
be good because this is even before
technology some of these reaction
reactions and deaths are very
questionable
[ __ ] got shot thirty times five
machine gun he's covered in blood but he
stood up and turned around shot back
that would definitely be like the
definition of like a throwback Thursday
or a flashback Friday clip I can't
really critique it too much because a
lot of the action that happened in the
United States or just around the world
at that time was very parallel the best
way to term it would be cowboy type
stunts so a lot of the action back in
the day used to be a lot wider punches
guys would do barroom brawl fights where
they do super wide hits and then over
the years guys just got a little more
realistic I'd say maybe back in the day
that was more along the lines of like a
7 if you were to compare it to some of
the other films that we watched earlier
today holding up in 2019 probably have
to give that a 5 or a 4 as far as
Bollywood is concerned that on a scale
of one to ten for realism I'm gonna give
that one a 1 a respectable one at that I
mean that's one thing you'll notice in
these Bollywood scene it's always one
verse to be gay so it's funny is that
they're playing out the car in normal
speed and then his running in slow
motion but somehow he caught up to them
[Applause]
well that's one way to take out four
guys at once hit them make them spin in
five circles crash their car and then go
over a balcony into a ocean I mean just
your standard jump 180 bitch-slap into
Hong Kong reaction Oh another Hong Kong
fall this is just any sort of reaction
where you get hit in the face and your
body turns horizontally and you do one
to two twists before hitting the ground
this term and this move was really
popularized throughout Hong Kong cinema
so a lot of the stuff predating back to
Jackie Chan days where a lot of the you
know Chinese type action or Hong Kong
action for for that matter consisted of
super curious how this is gonna resolve
fade to black out a whipping seed oh wow
entertainment value 1 out of 10 I'd give
that one a solid Bollywood standard 8 to
9 far as a realism is concerned I think
we're gonna stick with another Bollywood
standard we're gonna go with the solid a
1 there because my man chased down a
moving car made a car crash on its own
then not only dragged guys and fought
them but chose to fight 5 dudes with his
belt I think it's safe to say that
Bollywood is really pushing the levels
of not only just cinema in general but
definitely the action genre it's really
cool to be able to take a look at a
country that is really not scared of
breaking the brink of realism while at
the same time really showcasing their
scars in a really cool light for any of
your producers out there let's make some
movies like that here in America